and I suspect that communism originally
was not a Utopia I think that in the
same way as original Christianity it had
a particular kind of vision
and this vision is a society a mode of
organization within the society in which
humans can uh
coexist at scale without coercion
the same way as we do in a healthy
family right in a good family you don't
terrorize each other into compliance but
you understand what everybody needs and
what everybody can is able to contribute
and what the intended future of the
whole thing is and you everybody
coordinates their behavior in the right
way and informs each other about how to
do this and all the interactions that
happen are instrumental to making that
happen right could this happen at scale
and I think this is the idea of
Communism communism is opposed to the
idea that we need economic Terror or
other forms of Terror to make that
happen but in practice what happened is
that the proto-communist countries the
real existing socialism we placed a part
of the economic Terror of his moral
Terror right so we were told to do the
right thing for moral reasons and of
course it didn't really work and the
economy eventually collapsed and the
immoral Terror had actual real costs
right people were in prison because they
were morally non-compliant
and
that is the other thing is that the idea
of Communism became Utopia so it
basically was projected into the
Afterlife we were told in in my
childhood that communism was a
hypothetical Society to which we were in
a permanent revolution that justified
everything that was presently wrong with
Society morally but it was something
that our grandchildren probably would
not ever see because it was too ideal
and too far in the future to make it
happen right now and people were just
not there yet morally and the same thing
happened with Christianity right this
notion of Heaven Was mythologized and
projected into an afterlife and I think
this was just the idea of God's kingdom
of this world in which we instantiate
the next level transcendental agent in
the perfect form so everything goes
smoothly and without violence and
without conflict and without this human
messiness on this economic messiness and
the terror and coercion that existed in
the present societies and the idea of
that the humans can exist at scale in a
harmonious way non-coercively it's
untested right or a lot of people tested
it but didn't get it to work so far and
a Utopia is a world in where you get all
the good things without any of the bad
things
and you are I think very susceptible to
believe in Utopias when you are very
young and don't understand that
everything has to happen in causal
patterns that there is always feedback
loops that ultimately are closed there's
nothing that just happens because it's
good or bad good or bad don't exist in
isolation they only exist with respect
to larger systems so can you Intuit why
Utopias fail as
um as systems
so like having a Utopia that's out there
Beyond the Horizon is it because then
um so it's not only because it's
impossible to achieve Utopias but it's
because
what certain humans certain small number
of humans start to uh
um
sort of greedily attain power and money
and control and influence
as they become uh uh as they see the
power in uh using this uh idea of a
Utopia
why is my garden not perfect it's
because some evil weeds are overgrowing
it and they always do yeah right but
this is not how it works a good Garden
is a system that is in balance and
requires minimal interactions by the
gardener and so you need to create a
system that is designed to
self-stabilize and the design of social
systems requires not just the
implementation of the desired
functionality but the next level design
also in biological systems you need to
create a system that wants to converge
to the intended function
right so instead of just creating an
institution like the FDA that is
performing a particular kind of rule a
role in society you need to make sure
that the FDA is actually driven by A
system that wants to do this optimally
that is incentivized the route optimally
and then makes the performance that is
actually enacted in every generation
instrumental to that thing that actual
goal right and that is much harder to
design and to achieve see if the
designer system where I mean listen
communism also was quote unquote
incentivized to be a
a feedback loop system that achieves
that Utopia it just it wasn't working
given human nature the incentives were
not correct how do you uh incentivize
people when they are getting coal off
the ground to work as hard as possible
because it's a terrible job and it's
very bad for your health and right how
do you do this and you can give them
prices and medals and status to some
degree right there's only so much status
to give for that and most people will
not fall for this yeah right or you can
pay them or uh and you probably have to
pay them an asymmetric way because if
you pay everybody the same and they uh
you nationalize the coal mines
eventually people will figure out that
they can game the system yes so you're
you're describing capitalism
so capitalism is the present solution to
the system and what we also noticed that
I think that Marx was correct in saying
that capitalism is prone to crisis that
capitalism is a system that in its
Dynamics is not convergent by Divergent
it's not a stable system
and uh that eventually it produces an
enormous uh potential for productivity
but it also is systematically
misallocating resources so a lot of
people cannot participate in the
production and consumption anymore right
this is what we observe we observe that
the middle class in the US is Tiny
it's uh a lot of people think that
they're middle class but if you are
still flying economy you're not middle
class
right every class is a magnitude
class and
right
about classes is really like Airline
classes
a lot of people are economy have we
really business class and very few are
first class and summer budget I mean
some I I understand I I think there is
uh yeah maybe some people probably I
would push back against that definition
of the middle class it does feel like
the middle class is pretty large but yes
there's a discrepancy in terms of wealth
um
of the productivity that our society
could have yeah there is no reason for
anybody to fly economy right we would be
able to let everybody travel in style
well but also some people like to be
frugal even when they're billionaires
okay so like that let's take that into
yeah but uh I mean you we probably don't
need to be a traveling lavish but you
also don't need to be tortured right
there is a difference between Frugal and
uh subjecting yourself to Twitter listen
I love economy I don't understand why
you're comparing a flying economy to
torture